Oh sister I sold the house ah
smart mom knife did to me I'd look after
it you can't look after you so I get a
job or something a job doing - I don't
know thinking about hiring a woman to
cope around the house I want to put up a
sign you know looking for a mod and be
nice we're gonna have someone around
here let me tell you how it is there's
me and dogs them chickens then you do
you want me here and drunken cuz now
walk out right now told you you could
paint berries on the wall I think it
looks alright did you paint that happy
little ticket yeah
wanted to remember is happier days
how much what's your price for cars not
selling that one already sold I'm
finished
you can find Marlo's selling our
paintings from the front steps of her
little house here in Marshalltown Nova
Scotia I get you to look towards the
camera display mr. Lewis and smile maybe
you can do much better than me and
everything I want with you ever
[Music]
window-hole as I've already framed right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]